und über die reise vom kanzler und dem
vizekanzler olaf scholz und robert habe
kann ich jetzt sprechen mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habe
gleich aus montreal schon guten morgen
guten morgen nach deutschland sie sind
in kanada um mit der kanadischen
regierung zu verhandeln es geht um
energie partnerschaft jetzt ist nur die
frage ganz kurzfristig wird das ja
wahrscheinlich nicht helfen wir wissen
auch schon es gibt an der ostküste keine
flüssiggasterminals und es ist auch die
frage ob die gebaut werden weil wir ja
langfristig eigentlich eher zu den
erneuerbaren hin wollen von daher die
frage was kann ihr besuch jetzt
erreichen
genau das was sie angesprochen haben die
kanadische regierung bereitet sich
darauf vor grünen wasserstoff also durch
erneuerbare energien er gestellten
wasserstoff zu produzieren vor allem in
der region neufundland ideale
windbedingungen dafür und wir haben
erstens ein technisches know how und
zweitens einen großen bedarf also
energie ist ja mehr als ein den die und
fossile brennstoffe darüber wird auch
gesprochen werden aber sie haben recht
die exploration findet im osten statt
und die gelte wenn wir im westen statt
und die terminals sind nicht im osten
aber der schwerpunkt der reise ist
tatsächlich von der energie
partnerschaft für die zukunft nämlich
grünen wasserstoff das heißt aber
kurzfristig kann uns das ganze nicht
helfen richtig das heißt wir müssen dann
uns doch darauf
einstellen dass das schwierig wird
diesen herbst und diesen winter
ja aber in deutschland ist das problem
nicht die verfügbarkeit von lng das wird
immer wieder berichtet das ist aber
nicht der fall in deutschland ist das
problem die verfügbarkeit einer
alternativen infrastruktur zu den
russischen gaspipelines wir bauen jetzt
provisorien erst einmal und dann fährst
du terminals und für diese gibt es gas
ich habe mir gerade der letzten woche
die verträge mit den unternehmen
unterschrieben das heißt für die
infrastruktur haben die deutschen firmen
genug gas auf dem weltmarkt eingekauft
und werden ihn auch weiter einkaufen in
deutschland gibt es aber keine
infrastruktur die uns unabhängig von
russland nach die muss jetzt errichtet
werden deswegen ist anders als bei
anderen ländern dieses wo kommt unser
gas ja gar nicht die erste frage die
frage kommt das gas ins land und darauf
muss die antwort gegeben werden insofern
alles was wir brauchen haben wir wenn
wir die voraussetzung geschaffen dass es
ins land kommt ok dann schauen wir
darauf sie sagen wir haben genug das
heißt das thema energiesparen ist nicht
mehr das vorrangig
das gas für die infrastruktur die wir
bauen davon haben wir genug aber
selbstverständlich dass wir jetzt dann
eine kurze interpretation dessen was ich
versucht habe zu sagen haben wir immer
noch einen sehr kritischen winter vor
der nase wir müssen wir damit rechnen
dass putin das gas weiter reduziert wir
werden mit dem vollen speichern einen
sicherheitspuffer haben und wir bauen
alternative wege auf aber es bleibt
gemessen an den verbrechen des vorjahres
bei den erwarteten gas flüssen eine
differenz ein delta und das müssen wir
durch sparsames wirtschaften durch
einsparungen hinbekommen dass wir dieses
delta nicht zu einer krise werden lassen
das wird als politische und als
gesellschaftliche kraft anstrengung
bewältigt bar sein aber es ist eine
kraftanstrengung und deswegen kann es
natürlich auch scheitern wir müssen uns
da alle unterhaken und mächtig
anstrengen von ihnen jesus dass es
ungefähr 20 prozent sein werden die wir
einsparen müssen es soll auch demnächst
eine energie einsparverordnung kommen
was genau wird da drinstehen was heißt
das dann konkret und wie wollen sie das
vielleicht im zweifel auch überprüfen
das ist richtig die zahl ist ungefähr
minus 20 prozent gemessen an den
verbräuchen des vorjahres dann haben wir
eine ganz gute chance ohne wirklich
drastische notmaßnahme über den winter
zu kommen
aber 20 prozent ist viel das muss man
sich klar machen und das bedeutet dass
alle wo sie können einen beitrag leisten
die politik tut das auch wir haben eine
verordnung jetzt auf den letzten metern
die dann am ersten september bestimmte
vorgaben macht die betrifft den
gassektor ganz wesentlich aber auch den
stromsektor beispielsweise sollen
öffentliche gebäude nicht mehr zu
repräsentativen zwecken beleuchtet
werden denkmäler nicht angestrahlt
werden die schaufenster reklame in den
innenstädten soll zwischen 22 uhr und 6
uhr ausgeschaltet werden bei der heizung
gilt es für die privatperson darum dass
man sein system optimiert einen
hydraulischen abgleich durchführt noch
einmal eine wartung durchführt die nicht
regulierbaren wärmepumpen die dann
nachts nicht absenken können austauscht
da geht es aber auch darum dass wir
überschüssige verbräuche versuchen zu
vermeiden beispielsweise wollen wir das
private pools werden jetzt nicht die
meisten leute haben nicht mehr beheizt
werden also und das sind nur beispiele
von weiteren punkten sind also eine
ganze reihe von punkten die man auch
sehen und merken wird also es geht auf
der einen seite um sparen es geht auch
noch mal um entlastungen ist es auch so
dass ein drittes entlastungspaket ja von
der regierung geplant ist jetzt heißt es
aber von sozusagen von ampel seite nicht
gerade einheitlich die einen wollen
geringverdiener und mittelverdiener
unterstützen dann von herrn lindner
heißt es man will die mitte stützen und
vor allem möchte er keine neuen schulden
wie glauben sie dass sie da
zusammenkommen
indem wir unsere verschiedene medien
nebeneinander legen uns einigen ich kann
noch mal für mich sagen dass die
verschiedenen leistungen natürlich
jeweils ihren eigenen grund haben und
die kalte progression also den
steuerlichen ausgleich für die inflation
durchzuführen ist ein grund dann würde
ich gar nicht widersprechen aber ist in
der lage in der das land sich finde
befindet nicht der aller stärkste und
der erste grund der aller stärke und
erste grund ist das für den
demokratischen die demokraten den
demokratischen grundkonsens halten
müssen indem wir einen sozialen
ausgleich schaffen und das heißt für
mich dass diejenigen die weniger
verdienen stärker unterstützt werden als
diejenigen die viel verdienen die
gasrechnung die kosten sind ja kommen
wir auf alle zu dann sollten nicht
diejenigen die 60 80 hunderttausend euro
verdienen mehr bekommen als diejenigen
die vielleicht 16 18 oder nur 12.000
euro verdienen da muss mehr geholfen
werden als bei denjenigen die besonders
gute einkommen haben sagt der
vizekanzler und
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
vielen dank für das gespräch